you had a very special unique chemistry
with Sally Field it's on camera a Chloe
was off-camera you seem like the perfect
couple do you guys still communicate at
all I try but she no she doesn't she
doesn't seem to be as interested as I am
to have the relationship start up again
really yeah I understand that
so you thank you you do reach out to her
and II just it's like it's a one-way I
do silly things I drop her notes and
postcards and things like that
I'm gonna start sending money was she
the one that got away
is that what you were yes woof means yes
okay booze ain't good woof means
everything okay it's like Shalom it
means ever for a loja woof woof
you